Qué conclusión se puede sacar de este
apoyo de la otan aquí eft se puede ir
contento o Celestia a Ucrania quiero que
se vea satisfecho uno de los grandes
temores era la posible fragmentación de
la otan particularmente por miembros
suspicaces respecto del incremento en la
cantidad de apoyo tanto económico como
militar eso Aparentemente no ocurrió en
segundo lugar se mantiene el compromiso
particularmente los Estados Unidos y los
países más poderosos de occidente para
incrementar finalmente ese apoyo durante
el resto de la guerra considerando
Además de que este año es decisivo y
además tomando en consideración de que
estamos en plena contraofensiva
ucraniana en contra la federación rusa y
tal vez tercero de que se entiende me
parece a mí por parte de los miembros de
la otan y la misma organización de que
esto va a requerir un esfuerzo de largo
aliento la guerra no se va a terminar
este año posiblemente tampoco el próximo
Y eso implica un compromiso bien
significativo sobre todo considerando
los factores inhibitorios para mantener
el apoyo en particular el efecto
económico negativo que esto significa
para los países miembros por lo tanto yo
creo que en el en la conclusión general
esto es una reunión positiva para
Ucrania y para los países de la otan
y se ha hablado de que Ucrania solo hará
parte de la alianza Si gana la guerra un
hipotético acuerdo de paz podría
implicar la neutralidad de Ucrania o es
algo que la otan ya no va a aceptar
Bueno uno de los asuntos más difíciles
qué va a significar ganar la guerra y si
esto va en paralelo con declarar la paz
allí en general consenso en que a veces
se declara la paz pero eso no significa
la victoria para las partes beligerantes
excelencia ha sido bastante claro la
victoria para Ucrania implica la
recuperación de todos los territorios
que han estado bajo ocupación de la
federación rusa incluyendo crimea eso es
Aparentemente contradictorio con
presunciones asociadas a la paz que han
sido al menos reflotadas por algunos
analistas y que dicen de que una salida
potencial es el término la guerra pero
la posesión por ejemplo de crimea por
parte de la federación rusa algo que
Creo yo que Ucrania va a considerar
inaceptable En consecuencia me parece a
mí de que falta un largo trecho por
recorrer debido a que Victoria para
Ucrania implica la recuperación de la
totalidad de los territorios ocupados Y
puede que Victoria para la otan por
tanto signifique otra cosa quería
hablarle de otro tema central que ha
sido el levantamiento del veto Turco a
la entrada de Suecia ahora deberá
aceptarlo El parlamento Turco sigue
ganando tiempo y fuerza negociadora
erdogan con ello Y qué ha conseguido
hasta este momento
Bueno creo que una de las razones de
oposición tenía que ver por cuestiones
de orden local usted probablemente
recordará que se llevaron elecciones en
Turquía hace muy poco elecciones de las
cuales se resultó reelecto el propio
erdogan Y salvaguardando entonces ese
asunto de orden doméstico sumado además
a las declaraciones de Suecia de que va
finalmente tener una posición más
neutral respecto del tema curvo hacen
entonces posible la entrada de Suecia
pero claro erdogan sigue teniendo eh
poder al menos de veto dentro de la
organización y hoy día pasando esta
decisión a al parlamento creyó que
existe ciertas suspicacia O al menos
algo algún grado de incertidumbre de
cuál va a ser la decisión final pero a
mi modo de ver la entrada de Suecia a la
otan ya es un camino allanado